Voiceover: Before we get started,
I've got to tell you
about 3 great companies.
PicClick is the first.
It's a one-person startup from
my friend Ryan in San Diego.
PicClick gives you a
visual way to search Ebay,
Etsy, and other sites.
Ryan is already doing 1
million product sales per month
on PicClick.com.
Not hits, but sales.
Go to picclick.com to
see how he's doing it.
99designs, it's the largest
crowdsource marketplace
for graphic design.
When I used them, I wrote a description
of the design I needed, and
how much I wanted to pay.
I got a bunch of designs back.
I gave each designer feedback.
I picked the one I liked best,
and that's the only one that I paid for.
Try them for logo design.
If you need a blog designed, use them.
If you need app icons, use them.
There's so many different reasons
why you might want to use them.
Check out 99designs, and you'll see
why so many past mixergy
guests have used 99designs.com
And Grasshopper.
I've had them now as my
longest sponsor for a reason.
Not only does my audience love them,
but you might have heard
several guests here, on Mixergy,
say that they use Grasshopper.com
as a result of these messages,
and they love it.
It's the virtual phone system
that entrepreneurs like me love
because it offers us multiple extensions,
music on hold, call forwarding.
It gives you an impression
of having a big,
professional organization,
but also caters to your need
to travel and to be flexible.
Check out Grasshopper.com.
Here's the program.
Andrew: Hey, everyone. It's Andrew Warner,
founder of Mixergy.com, home
of the ambitious upstart.
I've got with me today Salman Khan.
He is the founder of,
well, an online school
that's launched and run
largely through YouTube.
Do I have that right?
Sal: Yeah.
Well, it's known mainly
for the video library
on YouTube right now.
There's 1,500 videos.
It is being used,
it's had over 16 million views,
200,000 unique users a month.
It is definitely the most used
education platform on YouTube,
and as far as I can tell,
looking at the other
open course intiatives,
the most used library
on the web right now.
Andrew: I went through
the courses in preparation
for this interview, and I saw
that you teach math, basic math.
You say you start out
teaching 1 plus 1 equals 2.
I got so into a history course,
that I almost stopped working,
and I said, "Andrew, you can't do this."
So you know what I did?
I used this program called Zamzar,
that's gonna rip your course.
It's gonna put it on my iPhone.
I'm going over to an
estancia here this weekend.
On the ride over, I'm gonna be
watching you teach me history.
It was that freakin' fascinating.
Salman: Oh, cool. I'm glad.
That's actually really good feedback
because I get a lot of,
there's a lot of
interesting discussion about
how credentialed someone should
be to teach a certain subject,
and most of my credentials
are in computer science
and in finance and math,
I did the history. I love history,
but I did that one, to kind
of push the boundaries,
to show that you don't have
to necessarily have a PhD,
you just have to have a
passion for the subject,
so I'm glad to hear that.
You hopefully won't have to rip it soon.
It'll be on iTunes by
the end of the summer.
It'll be on iTunes U, the
entire Khan Academy library.
Andrew: I'm gonna come back to that point
that you said you don't
have to have a PhD.
I want to ask you about
what qualifies you to teach
all these subjects,
because you're teaching
more and more of them.
You've got a course on how IPOs work,
on how to raise money
for a startup, all that.
But let me start off asking you a question
that I ask a lot of my other guests here.
How much money does the Khan Academy make?
Salman: Well, that answer could be,
it could be answered on a
bunch of different levels.
It is a not-for-profit.
That's a decision we can talk about
because there was kind
of a thought process.
I was being approached by some people
in the venture capital and
the entrepreneurial world
about starting it as kind of
either a social for-profit venture
or a pure for-profit venture
or a little bit of both.
But it is a pure not-for-profit.
There's a little bit of
advertising that comes in
and goes to the not-for-profit,
and we're being very delicate
about the advertising,
not too agressive there.
When I quit my job as a hedge
fund analyst in September,
I was making nothing, so I was
essentially living off of savings,
and very recently-
Andrew: Sorry, the video just
cut out right after you explained
that you quit your job
as a hedge fund analyst.
Can you pick it up from there?
Salman: Oh, yeah.
So, after I quit, I was
living off of savings
until about, I would
say, about a month ago,
where we've gotten some
fairly significant donations,
so now I can at least
take a salary to do this.
Not a hedge fund salary, but a salary.
(both laugh)
Andrew: The donations
are coming from people
who are hitting that donate
button on top of your website?
Salman: Well, you know,
there's a ton of people
who are hitting that little
PayPal donation, you know,
and that's anywhere from,
I've gotten donations as
little as 50 cents all the way,
but there's a lot of people
who just donate unsolicited,
100, 200, 300, 500.
I've even gotten a couple
that were 2-3 thousand
just from that PayPal donation button.
But more recently, we've gotten
some pretty significant checks
from people out here in
the Valley that, you know,
get us to the point that I
have a runway to have a salary
for at least several years.
Obviously, there'll be other
opportunities to backfill from there.
Andrew: What kind of people?
Salman: A couple of them are
venture capitalists in this area.
One gentleman, he's a,
actually, he's not in the Valley.
He's in Europe.
He's a pretty prominant
businessman in Europe.
There's another,
I mean, a lot of the people
are people in the tech space.
You know, they're not doing it
as an investment, obviously.
It's a not-for-profit, but I
think they're excited about
the potential here, the
potential for kind of disrupting.
I think the feedback I
get from a lot of them is,
look, a lot of people are doing this,
a lot of people have talked
about doing this type of thing.
It's kind of an obvious idea to
take videos from good instructors,
put them on the web,
and eventually do some
analytics around it,
do some self-paced learning,
and everything's gonna be great,
but no one's really done it.
The best to date outside of Khan Academy
is the open courseware
efforts at MIT and Stanford
and all of that.
That's essentially been
just videos and classrooms.
Andrew: Boring.
Can I say that?
Salman: You can say it.
I feel the ...
I'm a huge consumer of
their open courseware,
but you have to be really motivated
and sit through a lot of things
that you don't necessarily
want to pay attention to
to get to what you want.
Sometimes it's delivered
well, sometimes it's not.
It's kind of inconsistent quality,
and there's all sorts of
other things that occur
when you have a video
camera in a classroom
that make it a little bit weird.
I think they appreciate the fact
that Khan Academy is 99%
execution and 1% talk.
Andrew: Let me ask you this, then.
I got your resume here.
I actually went to the way-back machine
to see what you were up
to before you did this,
to see who you were,
and you had your resume up.
I'm looking at it. Pretty
frickin' impressive.
In addition to 3 degrees from MIT,
which a lot of us have seen
in news stories about you,
and the one from Harvard.
You worked at Oracle. You
worked a venture capital firm.
You worked for,
you were on a path to be
one of these rich people
of Silicon Valley.
You're not gonna be that now, right?
Not through this.
Salman: Yeah, unless they make a movie
about the Khan Academy, I won't.
Yeah, you know, it's funny.
When I was working at a hedge fund,
the six years after business school,
I was a senior analyst at a hedge fund,
and it was doing well, and
then my manager retired.
He encouraged me to start my own fund,
so I was on that track to kind
of be a hedge fund manager
and all of that, but the whole
time, I kind of rationalized
that the only reason why I'm doing this
is because I want to
one day start a school.
In my mind, I didn't
want to start a school,
write grants and go to the
department of education
and get a charter and all of that.
I felt it would constrain me too much.
I was like, no, I just
want to become really rich
and just do it on my own terms.
That was my rationalization
for just trying to generate
alpha day and night.
But, as the Khan Academy story goes,
I kind of got an outlet
for some of my ideas
with my cousins, tutoring them virtually,
and then the YouTube thing took off.
I wrote a little software app.
A lot of people are using that
and a lot of the vision
started to become concrete
a lot sooner than I'd expected it to,
and then it was just kind of
a little bit of introspection,
realizing that I got a lot
more satisfaction out of,
the hedge fund job, it is a great job,
even irrespective of how much they
may or may not compensate you,
but this was just 10 times more fun.
Just the impact, everything
I did on a daily basis,
it kind of added to this library
that could be around forever.
My son who's 15 months old right now
could use it when he's
18 or 30 or whenever.
That idea got really exciting,
and just when you think about it,
and you see people in
the Valley like this.
I think Silicon Valley
is an interesting place,
because you do see this.
It really isn't about money.
I think so many people,
they view the money as points,
and they view it as kind of a
how important was my
contribution to the world,
and I think with Khan Academy,
I get to do that without having
to play the whole, you know,
venture-backed startup game,
and what's interesting
about Khan Academy is
even though it's not
gonna make me any money,
and I'm not gonna be able to
buy a nice house in Atherton
and all of that type of thing,
in terms of just impact,
it is already, kind of,
it's getting more
notoreity than many already
fairly successful startups.
If I had entered the startup world
and I had an exit for 10
or 20 million dollars,
that's a huge win, but
those type of things are
a dime a dozen out of the Valley,
and the Khan Academy,
it's not like I'm, that's my,
the Khan Academy, I already
feel has more impact
than a lot of these, so
from that point of view,
it was just way more impact, way more fun.
Every day, the things
that I was contributing,
I felt it was contributing
to kind of a lasting legacy,
and just the letters you get from people.
This was also another realization.
When you work at a firm,
kind of the best thing
that could happen to you is
kind of a pat on the back
from the boss, or a nice bonus,
but in this, I'm getting
letters, like 20 or 30 a day.
These letters, some of
them are just thank you,
but some of them are like,
"I was gonna fail algebra
"until I started using these videos,"
or, "Now I want to be an engineer,
"and I thought I was bad
at math my whole life."
When you get stuff like that,
it really makes you say,
"Hey, this is what I want to do."
Andrew: How about this?
I saw one letter on your website.
Someone said that, I
don't know where she was
or where he was, but the letter went,
"Where I live, black kids don't
really have access to schools,
and my mother moved me so
I have more opportunities,
and my teachers weren't doing it for me,
and then I discovered your videos."
Essentially, that was the
story, and things changed.
Salman: Yeah, no, and that letter,
I actually put on my website.
I view that as the
letter that on some level
convinced me to really quit my job.
I mean, there were multiple
other moments over the last,
I would say over the last 3 years,
where Khan Academy, I got a
letter or something like that.
I said, "Oh, you know, maybe
I'll do this full time,
"or take time off from
the hedge fund world,"
and then I would look
at my finances and say,
"No, no. Maybe I'll do the hedge
fund world a little longer,"
but then I got that letter in
August, late August of '09,
and I got that letter
in the same week that
Khan Academy had gotten some
notoriety from the Tech Museum
and the Microsoft Tech Award, and
it was getting a little press,
and I just kind of viewed
it as a confluence of events
that were telling me that
I should be doing this,
but that letter, especially.
I still think to date, that's
probably one of the top,
definitely the top 5
letters that I've gotten.
I mean, you know, it's
on the level of this,
without me really doing anything
incremental for that person,
they just consumed these
videos over a summer.
It really changed their life.
Andrew: By the way, people
in the chat room are just,
they're so inspired.
I see Dan Blank saying, "This
guy is really inspiring.
"We're only 10 minutes into the interview,
"and he's already inspired," he says.
"Such strong integrity,"
from Joseph Jacks.
Everybody here, they're just loving it.
"Holy crap," from Joseph Jacks
about your 3 MIT degrees.
So you're blowing us away.
Let's do this-
Salman: Well, you know,
I'll add this as another
kind of thing about making
it non-profit, here,
is that the good will
that comes out from this
is just orders a magnitude
greater than anything.
I mean, I'm convinced if
I did it as a for-profit,
it wouldn't have had the
same level of good will.
There's a lot more there,
we could talk more about that in general,
but I think people respond well to it,
and so people are coming
out of the woodwork
to really help as well.
Andrew: So, here's what I'd like to do.
I'd like to ask you about
your vision long term
so I could continue to be inspired
and inspire my audience.
I want to find out how you got here,
and then I want to ask you,
how do you do it so well?
Because you're able to take subjects
that you didn't spend
your whole life learning,
but somehow, you make it
seem like they're a part of
who you are, and then you explain them
in an easy-to-understand way.
I want to learn how you do that.
Let's start off with the big vision,
so we know where you're going with this.
What do you envision in the
future coming out of this?
Salman: Yeah. Well, you know,
people know about the videos.
I'm gonna keep making videos.
That's probably the
highest return on my time.
I was talking to a foundation yesterday,
and they were like, "Where do you envision
"yourself in 5 years?"
I spend at least 60% of my time,
still going to make videos.
There's an infinite amount of knowledge,
and as you know, I teach things
that are not necessarily
in my core expertise,
but I make the part of my core
expertise so I can teach them.
Beyond just the video library,
I see it becoming a free virtual school,
and what I think that entails is
you have a video library,
you have self-paced adaptive
exercises you don't,
call them adaptive if you'd like.
That's already built.
Actually, I started building that before
I started working on the videos.
The videos are actually a
complement to the software piece,
and people can log in.
It's at khanexercises.appspot.com,
and it's all free.
You just need a Google account.
It's on an app engine.
People started coming out of the woodwork,
started working on that,
so it's an open source
project on top of that,
so not only will Khan
Academy be a virtual school,
but that code can then
be used for anyone else
if they want to make their own
island of education if they want.
But the idea is you have the videos,
you have exercises that start
you at 1 plus 1 equals 2.
They'll work you all the way up,
and they're dynamically generated.
They'll work you all the way up.
Right now, they go through about algebra.
The videos go well beyond that,
but the exercise I want
them to go through calculus
and chemistry, and
those keep building out.
We collect data on everything.
we know what videos you've watched,
when you've watched the videos,
what exercises you've watched.
We'll do heuristics on when you're stuck,
and then what I think would
kind of complete the picture
of a virtual school is,
leverage the community to do
actual peer-to-peer instruction,
so if I know that Andrew is having trouble
with negative exponents
and Sal who lives in Mountain
View knows negative exponents,
and I know both of your schedules,
i'll set up a peer-to-peer interaction,
and then you and I will have
a session not too different
than I was having with
my cousins 4 years ago,
and then we'll also record it,
so it also becomes part of this library
that we can collect all
of this data around.
Was that a good interaction?
I'll rate you, you'll rate me,
and then we could also see if there are
statistically-significant
outcomes on your performance.
I think there's a lot to be
said in the for-profit world,
there's a lot of people
doing video libraries,
and they're doing different
ways to collect data on it
and have the best videos,
and then there are other
people who are doing exercises,
and there are other people
who are starting to explore
the peer-to-peer learning,
but I'm pretty convinced
in order to do it properly,
you want to have all of them
together in the same place.
Andrew: Okay, so we got the videos today.
You talked about what you
have up on app engine.
I played with that game for a little bit.
It's interesting. You get to
learn and then you go into
a place where you take quizzes
based on what you've learned,
so to use the example that I played with,
it was what's 9 plus 5,
and if I didn't know the answer,
I could press the button to see a hint,
and the hint you showed
me balls underneath 9,
and then if I still
didn't know the answer,
I would hit the hint again,
and I would see 5 balls under 5,
and then I could answer it,
and then you keep track of it,
and so you got that today,
and then in the future,
you're gonna add peer to peer,
and then you mention that
there are other people
who are already doing this.
What about people like Cramster,
who's doing this already or, who else?
Who did I interview here?
I interviewed the founder of
University of the People, Shai.
He wants to create an online university.
How does this fit in with
what's already out there?
You know, I think a
lot of the focus so far
has been on platform, and I'm not 100%.
I'm somewhat familiar with both
of those 2 efforts you've had,
and I think in order to make
these work, platform matters,
but the platform really has to
have a core of really good content,
and that's what's going to
make people use the platform,
and I think right now
the value proposition,
and I think the reason why Khan Academy
has a lot of traction is
because it has, you know,
when people say, "What is Khan Academy?"
It's 95% content and 5% platform,
but I think that's what
gives us the ability
to eventually turn it into 95% platform,
maybe 50-50, 50% platform,
so I don't know what
these other efforts are,
but I have, I've even advised
a few startups in the Valley
about education and that,
without trying to be too blunt about it,
I think a lot of thier
problem is that, you know,
there are a couple of MBAs,
they have this big-picture idea,
which is not an incorrect idea,
but I think they downplay the
value of good instruction,
or they downplay the value
of really good content,
which I think is super
important in education.
Andrew: All right. Let's go
back to how you started this.
I feel like everyone
probably knows it already,
but they can't possibly.
Can you tell people?
The reason I feel that is
because lately in our space,
in the entrepreneurial space,
people keep talking about you.
I saw you on Hacker News.
I saw your story on Jason Fried's site.
Of course, a lot of us are NPR nerds.
We heard your story there.
For anyone who didn't hear how it started,
can you tell them?
Salman: Yeah, I was ...
Well, it depends how early you want to go.
If you go back to college, I
always did have this vision
of kind of creating a holy grail of
at the time, I thought it
would be a software-based
education platform,
but then obviously, my education got,
my career got derailed, I
ended up at a hedge fund,
we're in 2004 now, my
cousin and uncle and aunt
were visiting me from New Orleans.
My cousin Nadia was having trouble,
well, it just came up in conversation
that she was not placed into
pre-algebra for 7th grade,
and then I kind of said,
"Hey, that's a big deal.
"You don't realize it.
"It seems like a harmless
thing in middle school,
"but then she's not gonna
take algebra in 8th grade.
"She's not gonna take
calculus when she's a senior,
"and that's gonna really limit
her career opportunities,
"or if she wants, all
these other byproducts,
"and even her own self-confidence,"
and she's a really bright girl.
She was a really bright girl then.
It was pretty obvious, so
I made a deal with her.
I was like, "Hey, if you
are willing to work with me
"half an hour a day after
your school and my work,
"I'll tutor you remotely.
I'll be in Boston.
"You'll be in New Orleans."
She agreed, and we started doing it.
We just used Yahoo Doodle,
and a conference call,
and it ended up working out really well.
I mean, even within a couple of months,
she had not only done pre-algebra,
she was working on algebra stuff,
and then I started
working with her brothers,
and then other family
members and family friends,
and a couple of things popped in my mind.
I was like, you know,
1-on-1 teaching people
really works, even if it's virtual,
which might be kind of obvious,
but I was like, "Gee,
I wish there was a way
"that I could make this
scale a little bit,"
or at minimum, make it a little easier
for me to logistically handle
everything that I'm doing,
and so I did two things.
I started working on the software.
I started doing that before the videos,
because I wanted, you know,
when I started tutoring
even Nadia, I would point
her to random websites,
and I'd say, "Hey, there's
some exercises there.
"Why don't you play around with them?"
I didn't know what she did,
when she did the exercises.
I was very data-focused, and I was like,
"Well, I kind of have
to take her word for it,
"how she felt about it."
I'd keep pointing her to different things,
I was just like, let me
just write my own little
my own little JavaScript
scripts to generate problems,
and let me put a little database behind it
so I can track when she's doing it,
how long it's taking her,
all of that type of thing,
and then a buddy literally said,
"Hey, you know, why don't
you add some videos there?"
Because I was kind of telling him about,
"Yeah, you know, these kids,
"I keep having to do the
same lecture over again.
"It's getting hard to schedule.
"I have 5 or 10 kids
that I'm working with,
"and I have a day job."
He was like, "Why don't
you make YouTube videos?
"It might be useful for them."
So I tried it out, and the initial
feedback I got from my cousins
was that they liked me better
on YouTube than in person,
or virtually, or live,
and I think the takeaway
was it was less-stress,
they could pause and repeat.
They could do it on their own time,
there was none of this
scheduling situation,
so I got that feedback from them.
Other people started watching the videos,
and other people started
sending these notes,
like, "Hey, I got an A on my algebra exam
because of this," and at
first, it might have been
one note a week or one note a month,
but it got me pretty excited.
The ideas started to crystallize,
I said, "Gee, if I make this library,
"even if it's just useful to my family,
"like my cousins who are using it now,
"and my, I didn't have a son at the time,
"but my future kids, and anyone else,
"that's just a huge gift to our family,
"and if other people end up using it,
"that's even more neat,"
so it kind of became a fun outlet for me.
I was working, you know,
we had moved out to Palo
Alto a year after that,
so I was working east coast hours,
so I was done with work by about 2 p.m.
My wife was in medical residency,
so I had a lot of time, and as
this was a fun use of my time,
and it was kind of an outlet for
me to get this kind of education,
these educational ideas off my plate,
and I love mathematics.
It was also a way to
engage parts of my brain
that I hadn't engaged in a while,
so it was just a lot of fun,
and it was actually having an impact.
Then fast forward 4 years, you know,
September 2009, take it from there,
and now we have, whatever,
16-17 million views
and it's the most used
open course library.
Andrew: September 2009
being the day you quit,
being the month you quit your work
so that you can do this full time?
Salman: Right.
Andrew: You know what I'm
wondering as you're saying this?
If I had a relative who
wanted to learn math
or wanted to learn anything,
I might help them once.
Then after that, I might
refer them to a website
where they can go and learn after that.
Why would you spend so much time?
You've got a job, you've
got other things going on.
Salman: Well, you know, I think it's ...
You know, it was fun.
Look, if you work at a hedge fund,
it was a great job, and I have to say,
the hedge funds I worked for,
and I worked for one hedge
fund in particular for 6 years,
it wasn't the typical really
high-power type-A type place.
It was a really intellectual,
thoughtful type of firm.
My boss was a really great
guy who really focused on
kind of work-life balance.
But, at the same time,
it was a really good job,
but there wasn't a lot that you could say,
what have I contributed
to the world today?
Even the nature of the
hedge fund job itself,
you could do really good analysis
and then that investment goes nowhere,
and then you could get
lucky, and you could do,
so there's a lot of that,
and you almost crave for
something that you do every day,
where you feel like I
did this for X hours,
and that X hours was a positive
contribution to something.
It made the pie a little bit bigger,
and I think that's what gave
me a little bit of purpose,
and it gave me an outlet,
and it made me feel
like I wasn't, you know.
I talked to a lot of my friends
who are roughly at my stage
in my career, and I was like, you know,
it kind of dawned on me that look,
you're life is pretty valuable,
and what I was doing at the hedge fund,
I don't want to demean it.
I think it's a great job,
but I'd spent 6 years of my life,
but really what I had to show for it was
I had experience, I learned
to analyze securities better,
and I saw a lot about how
businesses work and all of that,
but what I really had to show
for it was just some numbers
in a bank account someplace.
It's like I really had no
actual tangible contribution
to show for it, and
this gave me that outlet
where I felt like these
years weren't wasted.
I feel that more and more.
Evey day, I almost feel
like my day is wasted
if I don't make a few videos,
or if I don't write a
little bit of software.
If I just sit a whole day in meetings
or if I'm trying to
fundraise or whatever else,
I feel like I'm not doing
what the Khan Academy
is supposed to be doing.
Andrew: Did you think at the
time that this might help
you prepare for the school
you'll launch some day,
or did you think that
maybe this would lead to
a school or software that
I can create and sell?
What did you think it
was going to lead to?
Salman: Once it got to about,
once the JavaScript
modules, once I had about,
I would say about 20 of them,
and I was using it with my
cousins and family and friends,
and they were using it,
it really was teaching them,
and you combine it with the videos.
Once the video library got to about 100,
and the combination of
it really was pretty good
at teaching people
pre-algebra through algebra,
I started to think very
seriously, you know what?
The school fo the future needs to have
something like this as
its operating system,
needs to have something
like this at its DNA.
I did, and actually I do
view, this virtual school
that we talked about earlier,
as, it is a virtual school.
It could stand on itself.
People could go to that virtual school
and use it to learn things,
independent of anything else,
but it could also be used
as the operating system
or the DNA for a physical school,
where you have a 1-room schoolhouse,
kids of all ages,
you know, you don't,
it's actually a very bizarre
way that people connect age
with different concepts,
so you have students of all
ages in a room together.
They're working on, for part of their day,
not their full day, for part of their day,
they're using technology to kind
of get their core skills going.
If they don't understand something,
there are other people in the
room that are going to help them,
so you have a lot of peer to
peer occurring in the room.
It could even occur across site,
and then the rest of the day is spent
doing real project-based learning.
There's a lot of talk about
project-based learning,
but not much of it is substantive.
I mean, real project-based learning,
where kids are actually
learning to program,
like they're really
working, building things.
They're actually writing things
that are being published.
They're actually composing music
instead of just learning to play music.
That's the whole aspect.
I definitely, I definitely
wanted this to become,
eventually the, and it does
seem like it is becoming
the DNA of a possible framework in school.
I did it with a couple of summer camps,
and the teachers wanted reports.
Can I see, you know, all the
students, where they are,
and we pretty quickly settled
on that kind of a paradigm,
when the teacher would walk into the room,
all the kids are working
at their own pace,
and the teacher just gets
a spreadsheet saying,
"Look, everyone's fine, but
those 2 kids are having trouble
"with adding and subtracting
negative numbers."
Instead of the teacher giving a
lecture and all of that type of stuff,
and admit,
the teacher just takes
those two kids aside,
does a very intimate session with them,
and let everyone else
work at their own pace.
Then, who are the next
two people who need help?
You could even, before the
teacher even gets involved,
you could have other peers helping,
all that type of thing,
so you can get more and
more technology in it,
you could get more and more data on it,
you can make everyone's
life a lot more streamlined,
and be able to do much
more intelligent things
on where you point people's energies.
Andrew: I could so see the
passion as you talk about this.
I can't imagine you were this
passionate about hedge funds
or venture capital or
any of the previous work.
Salman: Yeah, no, I was not.
I could see now that I'm not
working in those industries,
I can say it.
(Sal laughs)
You have to, I mean, those were,
I mean, I think outside
of the Khan Academy,
my job at the hedge fund was
probably the best possible job.
What was fun about it,
as you mentioned earlier,
I teach out of my core competency,
so a lot of what I do is
I really learn new things
and I try to learn it
at a really deep level
and that's really what I had
to do at my hedge fund job,
where every day, we'd
talk to an oil company,
and then the next day,
we'd talk to an internet
marketing company,
and the next day, we'd talk
to a chicken egg company,
so it was this kind of process of
you're always learning new things,
and you have to kind of
become a quick expert.
Andrew: I see.
All right, so you get these videos online.
I understand how today, when you have,
how many videos do you have?
Salman: A little over 1,500.
Andrew: A little over 1,500.
I understand when you get
to even 500 to 1,000 videos.
It starts to feel like something.
When NPR comes and interviews you,
when the BBC has you on,
starts to feel like something.
What about when it was just 100 or 200?
Did you ever feel at those moments,
wow, I'm just a YouTube producer.
It's me and the guy who's
creating the cat videos,
and he's got more viewers than I do.
Salman: Oh, yeah.
No, absolutely.
You know, I think in the past year,
a lot of friends and
family are trying to say,
"Hey, yeah. What Sal's doing is great."
But I think if you go back 3-4 years ago,
and I was kinda just going into the,
sometimes the guest room,
and eventually converted the closet,
making these YouTube videos,
a lot of them said, "What's Sal doing?
"Why is he spending all
of his time doing this?"
I had a lot of friends who
kind of like, you know,
"This is kind of weird."
Andrew: Tell me about how that felt,
because it's easy to look back and say,
"Eh, you know, that's what happened,
"and we got through it."
Tell me about how that felt so that
when I have that situation in my life,
or one of our listeners
has it in their lives,
where they are just like 100 videos
into a million-video project
the way you were back then,
and no one believes in them
and they doubt themselves,
they could identify with you.
So what was it like for you?
Salman: You know, I
think what allowed me to
kind of keep up a high level of energy
and stay motivated and want to do it
is that I didn't care if it
ever got to where it did get.
I was pretty happy with the,
I guess you could call
them small successes.
I was excited that 20
people a day were watching,
20 people who I didn't know
were learning math from me.
The idea that even if I
were to get hit by a bus,
20 people a day, even if
it didn't grow at all,
would still learn math from me.
That, to me, was a
pretty profound concept.
For me, just a couple notes a day,
and that idea were enough for me to say,
"Hey, this is a project worth my time."
I mean, it is, if at minimum,
no non-relatives watched it,
but if my son, when he's 18 years old,
is able to learn a little bit
of algebra or calculus from me,
that by itself makes it worth it.
I mean, that by itself
makes it a neat project.
I think in those early days,
I was just excited about the
small, that small impact.
That was enough.
Now, in the back of my
mind, it was growing.
I said, "Well, if it keeps
growing at this rate,
"Then right now, there's 20.
"Next month there might be 30,
"and, boy, in a year, we'd
have a couple thousand,
"and in two years, you know ..."
Exponential growth, it
happens pretty fast.
So that, I was like,
that would just be gravy
on top of everything else that happened.
Andrew: Did you have a
moment where you doubted it?
Where you were down on it?
Where you said, "What am
I doing here in the closet
"or on my computer, wherever it was?"
Salman: You know, I never did,
although I did have a lot of ...
I never doubted it, and
I'll tell you one of the,
I'm a bit of a stubborn
character, and I did early on
have people say, "Who
do you think you are?"
Like, you know, I've had
friends who are schoolteachers,
who are academics.
Not all of them, some of
them were very supportive.
They thought it was cool.
In general, I got kind
of negative push-back
from people who never
experienced the videos.
I think there's two camps.
People who actually experienced the videos
and said, "Wow, this is
kind of a cool way to learn.
"It was strangely engaging
and strangely addictive.
"It kind of got me excited about things,
"and it was kind of entertaining."
Those people are almost
universally supportive,
but a very small subset of my,
of people who were close
to me actually did that.
They actually took the
time to experience them.
A lot more people I know were like,
you know, there's billions of
dollars being spent on education,
there's thousands of people with PhDs
spending their whole life on
fixing the education system,
isn't it arrogant of you to think that you
and your YouTube videos are
gonna have any type of impact?
I mean, that's essentially the summary
of what a lot of people would tell me.
I would defend it a little bit at first.
I'd be like, well, in the back of my mind,
I would say, "Well, I think
a lot of those efforts there
are just spent on bureaucracies
and people talking about things,
but I wouldn't say that.
My response was, "Well,
you know, you're right.
"I don't think it's gonna, you know,
"I just wanna do my
own little small thing.
"If it has any impact, it has an impact,"
but in the back of my mind
it made me really angry,
and it motivated me even more
to make more and better
videos, and to do it.
To some degree, that's what,
like the history videos you talked about.
Every time I meet a small set of videos,
I started with pre-algebra and algebra,
I'd always get some push back.
"Oh yeah, that's nice and
cute what you have there,
"but this won't work for calculus,
"or this won't work for
differential equations or physics,"
and I'm going, "Oh, maybe you're right."
But then I'd go home, and it's like,
"I'm gonna show that person.
"I'm gonna fix up the calculus
and the differential equations."
Then you immediately get the push back,
"Oh, this might work for that,
"but it won't work for the humanities,
"it won't work, and you
won't be able to do that.
"You're gonna have to get other people."
I mean it's amazing how
many people still tell me,
"So, you're gonna have
to get more people on."
I'm open to it. I'm not
like against getting others.
In fact, when I started,
I thought that's how this would happen,
that there'd be 20 of us doing a large,
but it was actually hard to.
A lot of people would say,
"Yeah, that's awesome."
At parties, they'd be like,
"Yeah, I want to make videos,
"and that would be so cool,"
but when it actually comes
down to actually sitting down
with the tablet and
recording YouTube videos,
no one really did it.
Even now, there's a lot
of assumption of like,
"Oh, well, you're not gonna
be able to do all of K-12,"
and I'm like, "Part time, for 4 years,
"you know, I was working in a
hedge fund most of the time.
"It's pretty much 90% of
K-12 math has been done.
"If you extrapolate that full-time,
"it's not gonna take long to do it."
I'm not gonna say I'm the
only person that has to.
I actually want other people to do this,
but they're not doing it,
so if they're not doing it,
and I want to do it anyways,
so I'm gonna do it.
It is a bit of a motivating force
when people kind of question your validity
or your ability to execute on something.
It ignites a little fire
in my belly a little bit.
(laughs)
Andrew: Yeah, I've seen that.
I've felt that in myself, too.
All right, so how do you do it?
How do you do it so well?
Let me just ...
Actually, why don't you
start out by describing it?
Maybe I should have done that
earlier in the interview,
but I think, why don't we start
out with you describing it first?
Salman: Yeah, you know, the
videos, you don't see me.
They're black background
almost universally.
Some of them don't have black backgrounds,
but they have black backgrounds,
and I'm just writing in
colors that I think look nice
while I talk, while I narrate the video,
and the form factor started, two things,
this was essentially what
Nadia was experiencing
when I was doing those initial
live virtual sessions with her.
She didn't see me.
We just had a conference call going,
and she just saw what I was writing,
and so it worked with her,
so I said that'll probably work.
I also wanted it to, I didn't
have good recording equipment.
I didn't have a video camera.
Even if I did, I even
thought about at one point,
maybe buying one, but
it's really difficult.
Even if you get a really
nice video camera,
you have to get your lighting right,
then you have to get your own microphone.
I mean, all sorts of crazy
things you have to do
to make it look professional,
but if you just do a screen capture
with a USB headset,
and I started with Microsoft Paint,
and now I'm using little fancier stuff,
but it's all, I'm still
using Smooth Draw 3.
It's a piece of freeware.
It comes off a lot better,
and the feedback I get from people,
and it's kind of obvious now in hindsight,
that it's actually much
more intimate form factor.
It doesn't feel like I'm
on the other side of a room
lecturing to you.
It literally feels like we're
either beside each other,
and we're looking at the same blackboard
or the same piece of paper,
or it even feels like I'm, what
my narration is your thoughts
on some level.
So the form factor both,
I think, is compelling
to a lot of students, and
it's really easy for me.
I literally just have to press record,
start the screen capture going.
I don't have to comb my hair.
I don't have to shave.
I don't have to do anything,
and I just start talking
and start teaching.
The question of how I do it,
things like a lot of the algebra content,
I do a lot of that in real
time, very conversational,
a lot of the example problems I do,
in the early videos, I actually
made them up on the fly,
which I realize that kind of
wastes a little bit of time,
but I always do them on the fly,
and I think that gives
students a lens into concepts
that they don't normally see.
I mean, in a textbook, or
in a traditional lecture,
you always have a finished product,
that the teacher is seeing the example,
they've done the example.
Maybe they've done it 6 times that day
for the last 20 years,
and you never see them,
you never see the art of the problem,
and you never see it solved in real time,
and I get a lot of feedback.
Students like to see me go
down a little path and say,
"Oh wait, wait. That's not right,
"but I did it because it looked like that.
"Let me back up and go
down this other path."
They really appreciate that
informal conversational
kind of thinking out loud style.
For the more preparation-intensive topics,
like when I did cellular respiration,
or the French Revolution.
These aren't things that,
you know, I was exposed
to them in my education,
but they weren't something
that I would, like,
if you had bumped into
me 2 years ago and said,
"Sal, tell me everything about,
"tell me how many ATPs are
generated by this stage
"of cellular respiration."
I would have been like, "Well,
I took it a long time ago."
Those type of things I
do spend a lot of time
immersing myself in the subject matter.
Andrew: So tell me about that.
Tell me about the process.
How do you absorb that knowledge,
and then we'll get into how do you share
a tough topic with someone else?
How do teach it?
How do you get the knowledge
in your head so quickly?
Salman: You know, well, I try to,
I just try to read as
many things as I can.
I think, you know, to some degree,
obviously Khan Academy
is dependent on the web.
You'd need YouTube and all of that,
but it also needed the
web for my own preparation
because in kind of the old days,
you'd only have one source.
You'd have your textbook or whatever,
and that's very limiting,
but now you literally, you have textbooks,
you have things like Wikipedia,
you have random professors,
random people on the web,
explaining concepts.
You know, 90% of them are
explaining it the same way,
but that 10%, they'll say something,
and it just clicks in your brain,
and it was like, "Oh, why
didn't everyone just say that?"
That's the most,
and then you have all
these other, you know,
I'm actually a big fan of, I think,
well, this is kind of a commentary
in the publishing industry.
I think textbooks are
written not to teach.
Textbooks are written
to impress school boards
and to be these impressive, weighty,
you know, tombs, as opposed to something
that a student could digest.
I actually think a lot of the, whatever,
teach-yourself books that
you get in the library
for $10 or the Barron's
Calculus the Easy Way,
Biology the Easy Way, these
are actually really good texts.
They shouldn't be downplayed.
You start with something like that,
and when you have questions, you're like,
"Okay, that kind of gave me the overview,
"but I still don't understand
exactly what happens
"at this stage or that stage."
Then you can use texts
as reference, dig deeper,
use Wikipedia as a reference.
Then when I really get to
some really core question,
I was doing immunology,
which I'm not an expert in,
and in one part of my
wife's immunology textbook,
she's a doctor, so she has
her immunology textbook
from medical school, and
I was digging through it.
In one part of it, it
was saying, "B-cells,
"they need to be exposed to
the antigen to be activated,"
and then another part, it says,
"Well, helper T-cells activate B-cells."
I had these questions, I was like,
does both have to happen,
or just one of them,
and I couldn't find it anywhere.
I couldn't find the answers, so I
literally just called up a friend
whose a professor of virology
at Duke, and I asked him.
I was like, "Look, I know this
is a really stupid question.
"You're gonna judge
me, because you're like
"why does Sal, I shouldn't
be doing immunology videos
"if I don't know the
answer to this question,"
and I asked him.
I was like, which one?
He's like, "Oh, that's actually
a very interesting question.
"There are certain types of B-cells ..."
and he's like, "It's an area
of research of why that is,"
and this and that, and it's
completely not in the textbook.
I think, very quickly, as
long as you're really kind of,
if you're asking yourself
the right questions,
and you really are focused
on getting down to a
distilled intuition of a subject,
it doesn't take long before
you can really get to
kind of fundamental questions
that even experts in the field say,
"Hey, that's an interest ..."
There's this other, I
talk to a lot of friends
who have PhDs, are professors,
or doing PhDs, or whatever,
and sometimes if I meet them at a party,
I'm like, "Oh, you know,
I'm gonna do a video on this
"probably next week, and I have this one
"question about, it's like
a fundamental concept,
"something that a first-year
grad student should know."
And they're like, "You know what?
"That's something I always wondered,
"but I didn't really have time
to address it in my education,
"and I had qualifiers to pass,
"and I was probably
embarrassed to even bring it up
"inside of my department, and so
"I really don't know the answer to that."
One, that makes me feel a lot better,
but then we would kind of
become on a mission combined
to get that question answered,
and I would be kind of their
layperson that would say,
"Hey, this guy's wondering, you know,"
so if you want to know where
I think I'm adding value
beyond people who have
spent more time in the field
is that I have the luxury
of spending as much time
as I want on core concepts,
and I think core concepts
are the most important
because that's where you build
your intuition of a subject.
When I started chemistry,
before I even started,
I just played with the
Periodic Table for like a week,
just to make sure I understood the nuance,
why was it structured that way,
why is the pattern,
how did it come about,
as opposed to it's just there,
and how do you interpret it?
How did the first people even think
of making a periodic table
and things like that.
I get that luxury, and
PhDs and grad students
and professors don't have that luxury
of really understanding the core.
You know, a friend of mine,
I haven't done quantum
mechanics videos yet,
and I had a friend who was
explaining to me a little bit,
and he was like, "Oh, yeah.
"If you have this electron,
it's moving in this chamber,
this theoretical chamber,"
and I was like, "Oh, why
is it changing direction?"
He's like, "That's a good question."
I mean, it's like one of
these fundamental examples
that every first-year quantum
mechanics student learns,
and the teacher doesn't go over that.
They just say, "Oh,"
and they give equation,
and you kind of learn to mimic
in and so on and so forth,
but everyone's afraid to ask
these very basic questions.
I ask them, eventually
I get an answer to them,
and I think when I teach it,
I'll answer those questions,
and then people don't have
those gaps in their head.
Andrew: It seems like the Khan Academy
is great for teaching
Khan, for teaching you,
because you now are going
through the ideal university.
Can you talk about how knowing
that you're going to teach
what you're learning affects
what you're learning?
Salman: Oh, yeah.
Well, you know, it puts
the bar so much higher.
I mean, I think in most,
like I'm gonna start doing
organic chemistry soon,
and when you're taking organic chemistry,
and I took organic chemistry in college.
You're goal is really to get an A,
and if you're especially
intellectually inspired,
maybe to get another
level of understanding,
but there's all these other pressures
that are going on in college,
your grades and social
pressures and other classes
and all of that,
and now, I know I'm gonna explain it,
and I know, from the math
videos, there's a certain brand,
there's a certain standard
that people expect,
that I'm not just gonna
throw something at you
and say memorize this,
or I'm not just gonna say,
like, "Oh, this is beyond you.
"Don't try to understand it."
The standard people expect from me
is that I will give them an intuition,
and I will distill it down into concepts
where people say, "Oh
wait, that's obvious.
"That's all that thing is
saying about the universe."
And so that's the standard I
hold myself to when I learn it,
so it doesn't take long,
actually, to learn something
of a level where you can
get an A on most exams
at most schools, but
it's a whole other level
where you're getting to the really deep,
why is this intuitive,
or why does that expression
look the way it does,
or how is it related
to another expression?
It's hugely motivating while I'm learning.
I mean, it keeps me
going a little bit deeper
than I think most anyone would
if they were just doing it
for getting a credential.
Andrew: Don't medical
schools teach by showing,
doing teaching method, where
the student gets to learn it,
gets to do it, and then has
to teach it to someone else
because when you teach
it, you really absorb it?
Salman: Yeah. No, and I'm
a huge believer in that.
I mean, that's, you know, when
I talk about the virtual school.
That's why I think the
peer to peer is huge.
I think mastery comes
not just from being able
to do a lot of problems.
It really comes from that
exercise of teaching it.
I mean, I found it with my own experience,
but if you have kids all over
the world teaching each other,
and that's why you have
that 1-room schoolhouse
all of a sudden,
I think you're just gonna
have a whole other level
of mastery that doesn't exist right now.
Andrew: All right, so how do you teach?
How do you teach tough topics?
Teach us how to teach,
because we're all gonna
have to teach our employees,
we're gonna have to teach
people who we work with,
we're gonna have to teach others online.
Salman: Right.
Well, you know, I think there's
a couple of things here.
You brought up an
interesting point just now
when you talk about teaching employees
and teaching others.
I'm actually advising some tech companies,
where they want to build
Khan-type applications
on their platform and this and that.
At first, I was writing traditional specs,
like you would expect a
product manager or whoever
would write at a company.
I was like, this is silly.
I make YouTube videos,
why don't I just do YouTube specs?
I would literally just make a screen shot,
and I would just explain what
the interaction should look like,
and it's 10 times better,
so I think to a large degree,
just the form factor makes it way better
than if I were to write a white paper,
write a spec, or even if I
were to sit at a whiteboard
and use my hands and face to drive it.
One, I think the form
factor of screen capture
with hand-drawn writing
is pretty powerful.
Some people told me that cognitively,
just seeing typing or seeing
a powerpoint presentation
doesn't really stimulate the brain,
but seeing someone write
something handwritten
actually does, and I
kind of feel like that.
It's also easier for me to produce.
Beyond that, I think there's,
you know, what I do is
just get as comfortable as you
possibly can with the subject,
and once you get that comfort,
don't script the video.
Make it as relaxing as possible,
have fun while you're doing it.
There's actually a gentleman
who's going to start
translating some of the videos into Urdu,
and my one feedback, he
did some great videos,
but I was like, have more fun.
Energy carries over in our voice,
especially when you don't see the face.
You really have to have a
lot of energy in your voice,
and if you're not having fun,
the student won't have fun.
Have fun, be relaxed, but really
know what you're talking about.
Like, don't throw out buzzwords
without really knowing
what is going on behind it.
If you're at a company,
I actually think the
way Khan Academy teaches
would actually be ideal
instead of whitepapers,
instead of a lot of what
goes on inside of companies
to teach people how to do things.
Just teach your peers, and
teach it as it really is.
Don't try to look smart yourself
by throwing out buzzwords
that you don't necessarily understand,
or that you heard someone
else you think is smart say.
Just say it in as down-to-earth
of a style as you can.
Be frank if there is something
that you don't understand,
and I think people will
respond well to it.
Andrew: What about the way
that you give background
before you get into the subject?
How do you do it?
Salman: You know, I think
throughout this process
of making 1,500 videos,
I've gotten very good at
being a train of thought,
and I think a lot of
people when they teach,
they actually close down,
they actually shut off
a lot of their thoughts
that may be embarrassing,
that like, you know,
but when I do a problem,
there is a little bit of a
neuron that reminds yourself
that a negative times a
negative is a positive,
and maybe even remind
yourself why that is,
and remind yourself, you
know, all of these things
while you're doing a problem,
and I lay all that stuff out there.
Even if you're watching
the vector calculus videos,
it's literally, I don't assume anything.
I'm literally doing
stream of consciousness.
Every thought that's going in my brain,
you're actually getting on paper,
so there's no skipped steps, if you will.
I think there's that.
Before I do the video, I
do try to really make sure
I understand the big picture really well,
and probably, what I think
you're talking about,
where I give the background,
that's me articulating the big picture,
just so I have a framework in my head
of what we're even doing.
I think a lot of times, in all subjects,
once you start getting into it,
you almost forget what you're
doing in the first place,
and while I'm doing it,
I like to remind myself,
"What are we even doing?
We're on step 50 of this equation.
What was the whole point to begin with?
It's good to remind yourself,
it's good to remind
yourself from the beginning.
It's not some artificial
teaching technique.
It's literally, I'm reminding myself.
I'm reminding myself this is why
we're doing this problem right now,
and I think it's valuable for the student.
I think whatever keeps my energy level up
while I do the video, will
also keep up the engagement
and the energy level of the
person observing the video.
Andrew: I see.
People have to get that French Revolution.
I can recommend it before I've
even finished watching it.
It was so good.
You even gave us a
little bit of background,
and you said, "Well, the
French supported America,
"in the American Revolution,"
and I just thought,
wow, I wouldn't have
even thought to include
something like that, but
it really does help me
understand what's about to happen here.
It does, it's a great reminder.
How do you make it feel
interactive, when it's just you
and it's not even your face in the video,
how do you make it feel like
you're engaging the person?
Well, you know, I think
there's a couple of things.
I think, once again, we
talked about the form factor,
how it looks, but it's also the videos are
on average 10 minutes.
These history videos go a
little bit longer than that.
But I think because it's 10 minutes,
the person goes into that
video wanting that video.
It's not like they're
getting a 90-minute lecture
which may engage them for part of it.
I mean, it's almost like, the
act of clicking on a video
is almost like asking a question.
Like, "Tell me more about
the French Revolution,"
or, "Tell me more about
Napoleonic Campaigns in Russia,"
and so it's literally just addressing
that exact need you have right there,
and I think the other thing's just,
you know, I think it's the form factor.
it's a little bit of my tone.
I'm conversational.
I mean, literally, the
tone I use in the video
is not at all different than
the tone I'm using right now.
it's not at all like a lecture.
"The next step in this,"
it's not that at all.
Andrew: How many of them do you do a day?
Salman: It depends what I'm doing.
When I was doing French Revolution
or when I'm doing some of the more complex
biological biochemistry-type mechanisms,
then I'm lucky to be able
to do 2 or 3 in a day.
There's other things that
are taking up my time now,
which I'm trying to shut off.
I mean, running an organization,
well, I'm trying to automate
as much of that as possible,
but right now, I'm doing
a lot of worked examples
for the Monterey Institute
in Algebra 1 worked examples,
where they just gave
me a bunch of examples.
I'll say, "Yeah, I'll do them for you,
"as long as I can put
them on Khan Academy."
These are just literally
just algebra problems,
so I'm doing right now
about 10 videos a day
for the algebra problems.
Andrew: And who is this for?
For the Monterey ... ?
Salman: Monterey Institute
of Technology and Education.
They got a grant to build this course
and this and that, and this
is another interesting thing.
As you know, going back
to what we talked about
in the very beginning.
A lot of people in the
world are talking about
making open video content available,
and we should get good
teachers to put stuff up,
and we'll do all this analytics.
When it comes to execution,
there's, you know, they had
gotten this, and I told them,
I was like, "Look, I don't
know what you're doing,
"or how much money you're spending on it,
"but whatever you're
spending on it, you know, "
I'm sure I'll be able to do it
for, like, a tenth of the cost,
"as long as you're willing
to donate it to Khan Academy,
"and I think you're gonna
find it more engaging
"because it's not gonna be
scripted, it's just gonna be."
And they're like, "Oh, great.
"We've written all the problems.
"We can send you the scripts."
And it's just like, "Don't
send me the scripts.
"It'll ruin everything that is
good about the Khan Academy."
And so they sent it,
and I've, over 10 videos
a day, you very quickly,
you can churn out about
100 videos in not too long,
and they'd be done.
I think when they probably started,
they thought it was this
huge, grand project,
that'll actually be
done in a couple weeks.
Andrew: I've got one other question here,
and I wasn't sure if I
should ask it or not,
but I've got to ask it because
I think it's important.
You and your wife, you moved to one of
the most expensive parts of the country.
you're living in Northern California.
You're living around people
who are making tons of cash.
I gotta believe you've got
some expectation of lifestyle
and your wife does too,
and suddenly you come home September,
and you say, "Honey, I quit."
How do you deal with that?
How did the two of you ...
What's the story there?
Salman: Well, you know, I think it's ...
Well, you know, I think
the Sal before marriage
and before son would have
been much more obsessed
with kind of keeping up with the peers,
in terms of lifestyle and all of that.
Well, you know, I think once you ...
When I really seriously introspect
on where I find joy in my life,
it really does not come from a,
we're not living like,
I have saved enough
from my hedge fund days.
Not a lot by Valley standards,
but enough for me to not feel like
living off of savings for
a year was going to kill us
or prevent my kid from going to
college or anything like that,
so I'd saved enough there.
You know, we live in a
2,200-square foot house,
in a nice part of Mountain View,
which is not the fanciest neighborhood,
but it's a really nice neighborhood,
and the weather's good.
Andrew: Did you have to convince her,
did you have to explain to her,
"Listen, I gotta do this,"
or did she understand?
Salman: She, no, you know,
well, I think, a couple of the ...
The first few iterations
when I thought about it,
she was very like, "What,
you're gonna give up that job
"where every year you're making 50% more
"than the year you made before?"
I mean, the thing about
these careers lke hedge funds
or banking, really, is that they say,
well, you know, hey,
stick around next year,
and you're gonna make more than you made
the last 5 years combined,
and you're like, "Gee, that's, you know.
"Maybe I should," and she's like,
my wife is not materialistic at all,
but for anyone, it's just like,
"Gee, that would really like,
"not only allow us, yeah,
we could buy a nice house
and then we could even
support our parents."
I mean, there's all sorts of things.
You can always think of more
things to do with resources,
but when you really kind of
sit down and think about,
you know, I used to play a
game with a lot of friends.
It was like, "How much is enough?"
What do you need so that
you really don't need,
and everything above that is just gravy
in some type of competitive
whatever, you know, who knows?
You know, people out here,
they throw out 5 million,
10 million, 15, I mean, you know.
That's way above enough.
I mean, for me, enough
was below 7 figures.
I mean, I'm now taking a
salary with Khan Academy.
I quit my job convinced that,
"Gee, I'm a complete dummy
"if I don't convince someone that this is
the highest return on social investment."
I mean, for the cost of a preschool,
we can be educating millions
of people for all of time,
and it's not even like a school where
if the funding dries out,
that the school disappears.
No, the content will be there.
It'll be there on iTunes
and YouTube forever.
I was like, "Gee, I gotta be
able to convince somebody,"
and it is kind of,
and being in the Valley
is a big benefit there
because I think people
here more than anywhere,
one, there is capital.
People have resources,
and they see that.
They don't, you know, they don't,
they're not as swayed by the
touchy-feely nice picture
and please give some money and help.
They understand things at scale.
They understand when there's something
that has broad impact,
and they understand return on investment,
and so yeah, I kind of veered
off track a little bit,
but I think the simple answer's
I had enough, and enough
was below 7 figures,
but enough that I could put a down payment
on a 4-bedroom house in Mountain View.
We have 2 relatively-new Hondas,
and I'm now able to take
a salary from Khan Academy
doing exactly, you know,
I tell people if I had,
if you wrote me a check
for $5 billion 5 years ago,
I would have probably bought a house
maybe a little nicer than this house,
but my day would have been spent
making YouTube videos.
It wouldn't have changed.
Now I get to do it anyway,
and so why chase the $5 billion,
which already would have a low probability
of happening anyway,
and I'd probably just end
up 40 or 50 years old,
just probably with some
amount of money in my bank,
and just say, "Gee, what have I done?"
I haven't had ...
Now, with Khan Academy,
every day I'm excited
about what I've done.
I was like, "Okay, I've done these videos.
"Kids are already watching it.
"This is churning, gaining momentum.
"It could turn into a new type of school."
I mean, it boggles the mind.
I tell my wife every day,
I mean, literally every
night, I'm boggled by
how fortunate I am that
this wide-open opportunity
to do something really big
is just there, and no one's been doing it.
I mean, I want more people to do it.
I don't want it to be like only Sal,
but it's this wide-open opportunity
to really change things,
and all the technology has
kind of fallen into place,
and I think the way to do
it is on a not-for-profit,
because I think that's what
allowed all of the inertia
and the good will,
and it actually kept me straight,
in terms of my goals.
I think if I did it on a for-profit basis,
very quickly, I'd be like,
"Oh, in order to monetize it,
"I have to go to this part of
the market, and I have to get,"
and I start charging for some
part earlier than I should,
and that people wouldn't even learn.
Like you experienced a Khan Academy video,
and you say, "Wow. That's
a really good video."
If I put even a 50-cent
barrier on that video,
you would have never experienced it,
and for me, that wouldn't have been fun.
Let me put it this way,
if I had $10 million in the bank,
and 5,000 people watching these videos
versus I have 100 grand in the bank,
and 50 million people
are watching the videos,
that is a much more
satisfying outcome for me
than the former.
That's why I'm doing it like this.
Andrew: This is an
incredibly inspiring story.
I'll leave it there.
I'm grateful to you for coming here
and doing this interview.
I know you probably could have whipped up
5 different videos today for Khan Academy.
Salman: Oh, I know. I
have to catch up now.
Andrew: Sorry?
Salman: I have to catch up now.
Andrew: You have to catch up now.
(Sal laughs)
A few people, as we were talking,
came up with suggestions
for what you should do
to tweak your YouTube video
channel to get more viewers.
I couldn't understand it well enough
to explain to you what
they were suggesting,
are you open to those suggestions?
Should they email you directly?
Salman: Yeah, well, you know,
there's a couple of ...
Yeah, they should email
sal@khanacademy.org.
The software piece is
an open source effort,
and the few developers
who've started working on it,
I mean, they've been rock stars,
and I'm very open.
They're like, "Hey, you
know your knowledge map
that you drew out, it should
have arrows instead of arcs,
because, you know ..."
I was like, "Yeah, put arrows in there."
I'm a big believer in put stuff out there
and iterate, and keep repeating
as quickly as possible,
and it should, as long as
the people iterating it
aren't doing really silly things,
it should move forward.
Andrew: All right.
Well, thanks, guys.
If you have any feedback, any suggestions,
if you want to be a
part of this in any way,
sal@khanacademy.com
Salman: Dot org.
Andrew: dot org, right.
sal@khanacademy.org,
but you also have the dotcom.
Salman: No, I don't.
Andrew: You don't?
has the dotcom. I don't own the dotcom.
Andrew: Who is the evil son
of a bitch who has the dotcom,
who does not love kids enough to ...
Salman: I don't know.
It actually came off of,
I almost was able to get
it, and then someone got it.
I don't know.
There are people more sophisticated
at squatting domain names than I am.
Andrew: I guess so. Somebody
get that domain back for him.
If anyone out there is listening,
get that domain back.
All right. Thank you.
In all seriousness, thank
you for doing this interview,
and I'm really looking
forward to this weekend
and watching your videos.
Salman: Oh, great. Thanks a lot.
Andrew: Cool. Bye.